nice
trick shot hey guys
we're at the beach we decided to come
out
and enjoy a nice day at the beach we're
actually waiting for some friends so
we can relax and enjoy that view
isaac is itching to get into the water
we are in the oc
and if you know anything about the oc is
that they're crazy
and they're not shutting down anything
because of this pandemic so we decided
to be the only ones with
masks on out here when we were on our
way to come and set up camp here
we're wearing a mask trying to be trying
to be safe
but i mean this is like as far away as
we can get from people
which is like a decent distance i think
it's not super close you guys are
wearing sunscreen putting sunscreen on
yeah yeah
good i'm doing an extra layer good job
see how flexible you are
yeah go like that there we go see you
got it and the reason why we came to
this specific beach is because the the
waves
were reported to be higher i don't know
like you mentioned them by inches or
something i don't know
but they were higher and so that our
friend wants to like boogie board
and all that kind of stuff so we're like
alright let's do it oh does this beach
have crabs
i don't know yeah hopefully you guys can
hear us because i know it's really windy
so
apologies for the crappy audio what are
you thinking about
dinner and i'm always got my mind on
dinner you were thinking about eating
the crabs
no oh then what'd you think i was
thinking about dinner
yeah like me and my cousins like to grab
scraps when we come to the beach really
you grab crabs
that's so brave we like uh dig a hole
and then
when the water comes crabs come in what
or if we dig
a hole in the beach there's some crabs
falling
cool all right so you know how i talked
about my sun allergy it's still a very
real thing and that's why i brought the
biggest umbrella
ever that was just for me
i actually brought two umbrellas in case
anyone else wanted some sun
protection so right now it is about 2
p.m and i'm not supposed to be getting
into the sun until after around 3ish
because
between 10 a.m and 3 p.m is when
the sun is the harshest and that will
actually give me the most sun allergy
reaction
because we're here during the bad sun
time i have to just be under this big
old umbrella
all by myself so i'm not gonna be able
to get in the water until later
which is okay but i just think it's so
funny this
big ass umbrella just for
a dead bee are you gonna bury yourself
no i can't do that with my bare hands
i'll help you all day like i try to help
you i'd rather go
yeah true it's just for fun until the
friends come over
i see all these people with their beach
umbrellas and i'm like we should
invest in one because look at me just
holding this big old umbrella is just
kind of ridiculous you think it's not
windy or else you feel like it is kind
of windy i am struggling a little bit
all right so andrew and deanna and ray
joined us
and we're trying to set up this tent but
it is broken
but we're still trying to force it to
work it looks like they're summoning a
creature
hey ray you want some creepy crawlies
[Music]
oh you want them here you go buddy
oh no there's sandal in your hand uh oh
here let's eat it
here we go yummy
nice and happy
[Music]
you want to go in the water we'll go in
the water right now hold on
there we go we got the kite set up
how cute isaac's such a good big brother
had that natural big brother
instincts
how cute he wants to show that parents
are too busy trying to figure out the
tent
all right let's see how cold this water
is it's always cold
yeah oh it's gonna be fun
it's cold lava i dare you to jump in
your whole body
[Music]
oh dear i haven't had as much fun with
waves in a long time
here comes another one i see it coming
all right so isaac is now paddle
boarding
here we go
what happened
[Music]
prepare yourself for what like you know
sucking in the stomach
because like you and me both i have a
quarantine body right now that i'm
trying to get
get uh get rid of like i said in the
last vlog
i just started working out again started
running again
i gotta get this quarantine body out and
uh isaac's having a lot of fun
it's way too cold i'm like crying
[Music]
yes
[Music]
all right the sun is setting and we
spent the whole day out here and uh
it's a nice break from quarantine
lifestyle huh yep
yeah we haven't really gotten out and
done anything in a long long time
[Laughter]
oh that was good good job ray
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i don't know how to throw a frisbee
anymore
nice
[Music]
trick shot is that dude perfect
nice so ever since tiff started eating
the mini tacos from jack in a box
and it's not a brand deal tiff's been
non-stop talking about these uh
mini tacos and now she's convinced our
entire group that we gotta go get
jack in a box for dinner
okay go for it
take your picture
mama hi mama
isaac's getting a firsthand experience
of what it's like to be a future brother
because ray keeps running away and then
isaac needs to like
literally carry his uh him back over
here what are you doing with your beach
towel
oh because um i'm really cold yeah
yeah she's helping me figure out a way
where i can cover my arms
you have hands that's true here we go
nice stylish and that cheater print
pink cheater print that's the summer's
new look
[Music]
we spoke the magic words and now we are
magically here at the place in which we
can order
tiny tacos sponsor me because i love
tiny things i know they responded to you
on ig
oh yeah they did so kind of like there
was like a tip of the hat
i'm like yeah i see you oh thanks for
liking our tiny tacos
and i'm over here like can i get some
more
after this fun beach day i can really
use a
oreo shake
that's true beach hot summer day
waves water ocean sea salt
equals sea salt caramel ice cream hi
welcome chapter bugs how can i help
you today hi can i get an order of
chinese
tacos
[Music]
what we got over there we had some tiny
tacos
i mean you might be wondering i'm
wondering what are they doing
eating in their car because we are all
the way in sanskrit
even though the car would make it back
like you know battery we wanted to have
dinner with
their friends but because of the
pandemic
we're not able to dine in anywhere and
then i just kept raving about these tiny
tacos and we're like oh let's do drive
through and then while we're eating
our drive-through food we i can actually
supercharge my car
yeah so i put ranch on my tacos
from jack-in-the-box some of you might
think it's very strange and then
others would think duh that's the only
way you can eat tacos from jack and
vlogs how do anyone
else eat their tacos plain
yeah like isaac he's eating them plain i
just put some taco sauce
i ran out though nice you don't like it
huh did you like the taco songs
some days i'm a plain guy and some days
i'm a sauce guy
i'm always a sauce girl you're a saucy
girl that's why marijuana
mostly a plain guy this is cool i like i
like this picnic set up we got going on
in the middle of the parking lot there's
some skaters over there
this is like a like a pastime of like
college student life you know
right but now we're doing it outside of
college life as parents
yeah i like your tacos
how you like it number one
all right hey isaac if you had to use
your hand to show that you're on the
phone
what is the hand gesture
either one of those two yeah okay now
andrew if you were gonna talk on the
phone what's your hand gesture
we are old
[Music]
you